أن الأمم المتحدة مع
الاتحاد الروسي وأوكرانيا
وتركيا تحاول العمل على
احتمالات
تصدير الحبوب الأوكرانية ب عن طريق البحر أو
عن طريق أه براً عبر رومانيا
[الموسيقى] ،
وهو أمر
ضروري للسماح بفتح هذه الموانئ
لأن هذا ليس  حول أوكرانيا ،
هذا
يتعلق بقوة الفقراء حول العالم
الذين هم على شفا المجاعة بينما
نتحدث ،
لذلك سألت الرئيس بوتين إذا كان لديك
أي قلب على الإطلاق ، من
فضلك
افتح هذه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[تصفيق  ]
نحن نبذل قصارى جهدنا
لتأمين تصدير تلك الحبوب المهمة جدًا
من أوكرانيا وصديقي الموقر على
حق ، ليس لدينا سوى عدد من الأسابيع
لنكون قادرين على تحقيق أن
الرئيس بوتين لا يمزح في استخدام
الطعام كسلاح ،
دعنا نسميها فقط ما هي  هل يقوم
بتسليح الطعام ، فلديه حصار أساسي
هناك في البحر الأسود حتى
لا يتسرب شيء
[الموسيقى]
في البحر الأسود تحاصر
السفن الأوكرانية المليئة بالقمح
وبذور عباد
الشمس والعواقب  من بين هذه الأعمال المشينة ،
يمكن للجميع مشاهدة
[موسيقى
] أسعار القمح العالمية ترتفع بشكل كبير
، والدول الهشة
والسكان الضعفاء هم
الذين يعانون أكثر من غيرهم